MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So now after we introduced
the weak interaction
and the Feynman rules
for weak interaction,
we can now look at decays
of muons, and in this case,
the decay of a pion.
Decay of the pion is
specifically interesting.
And we discussed the
decay of the pion
before when it came to the
discussion of helicity states.
Now, let's look at this again
with the information we have
and what we learned.
Now, if you look
at the pion decay,
the two or three leading
decay modes are given here.
The one is where the pion, in
this case a negatively charged
pion, decays into an
anti-electron neutrino
and an electron, or V or the
W in a muon and an antimuon
neutrino.
If you look at this in the
rest frame of the pion,
we can see that the neutrino
and the lepton, charged lepton,
are produced back-to-back.
Now, the spin of
the pion is 0, which
means that the
opposite-direction outgoing
leptons have to have the
same helicity states.
Since the neutrino is massless,
the antineutrino is massless,
the antineutrino is
produced right-handed.
It is always right-handed.
The chiral state of the
neutrino and the helicity state
of the neutrino are
essentially the same,
because they're massless.
Means the projection
of the spinor
is basically the
same as a projection
of the spin on the
momentum [? direction. ?]
All right.
But the charged
lepton is massive.
If the charged lepton
would be massless,
the decay would not be allowed.
There would not be a
right-handed helicity
state for a charged lepton.
Now, this causes
quite some confusion.
And I've seen, even in this
course, some students being
confused by this.
I can write the, let's say,
right-handed charged lepton
and decompose its
right-handed helicity state.
So this is, let's say, the
And I can decompose this
through the chiral states,
the right-handed
and the left-handed.
And you have seen in
the previous lectures
that only the left-handed
component participates.
Now, you can also see
from this equation
here that if the momentum
and energy would be the same,
as it is the case for massless
particle, this would be 0,
this would be 1,
this would be 1.
And therefore, this
right-handed helicity state
would be the same
as the chiral state,
and it wouldn't be coupling
to the weak interaction.
Now let's erase
this really quickly,
because you want to
actually look at this decay.
And so now we have all the tools
together-- almost all the tools
together to calculate
this, the decay rates,
or the ratio of decay rates.
And you want to do this
in the pion rest frame,
so the momenta are given here.
See that the pion momentum is 0.
And for momentum, the
energy is equal to the mass
for the charged lepton.
And for the neutrino,
just produce
in an opposite direction.
So neutrino in this case goes
into negative d direction.
Then we can write
the leptonic current,
as we have just seen in
the previous lecture.
You see this 1 minus
gamma 5 term here.
Good.
And I could have just
called this left-handed here
and put this into the
definition of the spinor.
Fine.
When we put a real spinor,
this comes out immediately
[INAUDIBLE].
Immediately.
You have to keep this in mind.
The matrix element, then, is
a little bit more complicated.
And here is an additional-- so
you see the current here again.
You see the
propagator, and I went
into the low-energy
approximation here.
You see that instead of having
a [? q ?] square minus m square,
I'm just keeping the m
square component of this.
And then I have this part here
for the current, for the pion
current here.
And I simply parameterize
my missing understanding
or missing ability to calculate
[? non-prohibitive ?] QCD with
a form factor.
So I introduce this
form factor for a pion.
This is not an important
part of the discussion,
we just keep track of this here.
All right.
Then we can calculate
this matrix element fine.
We then have to be explicit
about the spinors we are using,
and we use the momentum
as defined above.
So this step here I'm
not doing explicitly.
If you want, you can go to
Thomson and read in chapter 11.
He gives quite some
detail on this.
All right.
So moving on, there
is one extra thing.
When we try to calculate the
spin-averaged matrix element,
we find that we don't have to
do any work because there's
a spin [? 0 set, ?] there's
only one state contributing,
so we don't have to do any work.
We just have to square
the matrix element.
We find this as a
solution here, and there's
an additional factor we
haven't introduced yet.
This is the Fermi coupling.
Again, this comes out in the
low-energy approximation.
And G Fermi is simply defined
over the coupling to the W
over the W mass
squared, as shown here.
All right.
Again, this is
just a factor which
is not relevant to the
discussion at this point.
But we can then, using
Fermi's golden rule,
calculate the partial decay
width of the pion decay.
OK?
So we just put in the
matrix element here,
and we replace the
momentum with the energy,
being equal to the
mass of the pion.
And voila-- we get this as an
answer for the partial decay
width.
OK?
If you now want to know some
experimental information,
like the partial decay
width of the pion,
charged pion, to
electrons over the muon,
you want to know what this
factor is, we immediately
can do this.
We don't need to know any
of the details F, G Fermi
as a structure
function of the pion.
All of those factors cancel out.
And what is left here
are the parameters
of the electron mass, the
muon mass, and the pion mass.
And if you just use
values like this,
the mass of the
muon with 205 MeV
and the mass of the pion 240
MeV, you find 10 to the minus 4
as a value for this ratio
of part [? indicators. ?]
And you see where
this comes from.
This basically
comes from the fact
that the electron mass
is much, much smaller
than the mass of the muon.
And factually, you can
expand this by the fact
that a right-handed
helicity state for a muon
can have a much
larger contribution
of the left-handed chiral state
of a muon, while this is not
possible-- or, that
is, the component
is much smaller for
the lighter electron.
And again, only the left-handed
component of the charged lepton
contributes to the
weak interaction.